PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Are you building
conversational
experience but would
like to cut down your
design and deployment time?
Stick around as I show
you the pre-built agent
templates in Dialogflow CX.
Hi.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia.
In this episode of
Deconstructing Chatbots,
I'm going to show you how
to decrease your design
time by using Dialogflow CX
pre-built agent template.
Although we are not
traveling like we used to,
we may be renting cars
to get around safely.
Let's see how our friends at
AlphaCar, a rental company,
can easily deploy
a booking agent.
Imagine you are a
manager at AlphaCar
and have noticed an uptick
in chatbot and email volume.
But you have a small number
of customer service agents
and not a lot of experience
deploying a chat agent.
That is a perfect scenario for
a pre-built agent template.
Let's see how to set
it up in the console.
The first step will be to
create a Google Cloud platform
account and a project.
If you already have one,
don't worry about this step.
Then go to the
Dialogflow CX console.
Click on the project
we just created
to import the pre-built agent.
And click Use Pre-Built Agents.
We see a number of templated
agents that we can import.
For AlphaCar, let's import
the travel car rental agent.
Select a desired
location, and create.
We now have the foundational
architecture for our agent.
Let's see how the agent
currently functions.
Best way to do that is to
navigate to the Test Agent
button and start a conversation.
Now that we know how
it currently works,
let's modify some of
the agent's responses
to make it customized
to AlphaCar, starting
with the default welcome intent
response on the Start page.
While we are here, let's also
modify the sign-off messages
at the end.
Now let's take a look
at our custom entities.
Perhaps AlphaCar only
offers a select few cars.
So let's swap out the
Mitsubishi Mirage and Nissan
Versa with Ford Fusion
and Chevy Malibu.
We will add some synonyms
and name variations, too.
Now that we've changed
these custom entities,
let's change the agent
option that are provided
in the middle of the flow.
We are going to click
on the Mitsubishi
Mirage and the
Nissan Versa pages
and change the necessary
information in the entry
dialog.
In production,
these page options
may be fed by
dynamic integrations
with an inventory CRM, but
for the purpose of this demo,
we will hardcode these options.
Now we have a customized
flow for AlphaCar.
Let's say AlphaCar knows they
get a number of questions
about forms of
payment, and they want
to be able to answer those
to contain their users.
Let's create a route group with
a couple of common questions,
like what forms of
payment do you accept,
and when will my
account be debited.
To do that, we will go
to create a route group.
We will name it Payment
Questions and add Route.
Then we will create an intent
for each of those questions
with some training phrases.
Once we have added these
training phrases and the route,
we save them.
We can enter the fulfillment
response now, as well.
For instance, we accept
Visa, American Express,
and Mastercard, and
your account will
be debited when you
return your car rental.
Now let's add that route
group to the Car Option page
under Add Route Type
inside Route Groups.
Great.
Now let's test the agent
using the simulator
to make sure everything's
working as expected.
Yay, everything seems to be
triggering appropriately.
Now let's add this
flow as a test case.
Test cases allow us to uncover
bugs and prevent regression.
We can then revisit
this flow and others
in the Test Case section, which
allows us to rerun all the test
cases, import and export,
and view the test coverage
for transitions and intents.
This will help us make
sure we're testing
every part of the agent.
It's also a good idea to look
at the validation section
to see if there are any
recommendations or errors.
It seems like it has spotted
similar training phrases
across multiple intents.
This can present NLU
confusion down the line,
so best to resolve that
by deleting or modifying
selected training phrases.
Let's fast forward to
being ready to deploy.
We're going to want
to use versions
to move our current development
environment into production.
A draft flow is updated every
time a developer on our team
makes a change.
As a best practice, we should
always test our draft flows
before promoting them
to production versions,
although we can always roll
back to previous versions
if any problems are discovered.
With that, our AlphaCar
agent is now live.
All that's left to
do is to regularly
look at the analytics
section to improve
the agent by assessing how
it's being used in production.
All right, so we just created
an entire conversational
experience to book a rental
car in literally five minutes.
That's exactly what pre-built
agent templates are for.
They increase the
speed to market.
Now it's your turn.
Explore a pre-built agent that
makes sense for your project
and share your experience
with me in the comments below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]